[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills polls
are closing across the u.s as election
results come in
but it is still too soon to tell how key
battleground states are going to shake
out in this election
right now we're seeing that biden is at
135 electoral votes
and trump is at 108. joining us to break
down the latest
is bloomberg politics reporter anna
edgerton anna thank you so much for
joining us this evening uh to start off
i want to talk about the
extremely high number of early voters we
saw this election cycle
over a hundred million people sent in
their votes before november 3rd and a
lot of them were young
voters can you talk about the potential
impact of
gen z on this election outcome yeah and
that's the hard thing about where we are
right now
at this point in the night is this
election has been so different than
anything we've seen before because of
the pandemic because of the truly
polarizing nature of the president
people either love him or hate him and
it's driven turn out to really record
levels
so right now we're looking at states
that have different rules when it comes
to reporting
so you have a state like north carolina
that has been counting their absentee
ballots as they've come in
you have a state like pennsylvania that
didn't start counting their mail-in
ballots
and mailing and absentee ballots until
seven o'clock this morning
so you know we'll definitely see those
results dribbling in the young vote was
definitely something that both campaigns
were targeting but especially the biden
campaign
you know they were really trying to
drive turnout around this
part of the electorate that is more
passionate than we've ever seen about
issues especially when it comes to
climate change
uh social justice and it's really hard
to get
young people to turn out historically if
that's different this year we'll see
when we get the final demographic
breakdown
thanks so much anna and i do want to
update our viewers that we are actually
at 209 versus 112 right now that's 209
for biden and 112
for trump anna heading back to you can
you tell us a little bit about
what we're seeing this evening and some
questions that we might have
uh heading into tomorrow morning if
people start to go to bed soon about
how this election is shaking out in
these key battleground states
well it's definitely looking like it's
not going to be a landslide and that's
one of the things that we were
looking at to see if you know joe biden
pulled ahead by a lot then we could go
to bed
kind of knowing what the result was not
really staying up for the
north carolina and pennsylvania you have
to count every single absentee and mail
and ballot but
it looks like we could really be coming
down to the wire in some of the swing
states
and that means that we could wake up
tomorrow and not know who was won
and of course we have the president
saying that he could come out
and you know declare himself the winner
when it looks like he has
enough support to do so and that might
be before are the results are counted so
you know just under to our watchers and
to our followers
if this is a vote that could uh you know
legally by all the rules set out by all
the states
go forward
and anna what's the likelihood of a red
barrage situation here
where like you mentioned a lot of states
didn't start counting
their early uh mail-in ballots until
today
and maybe people who voted in person
just happen to go more for trump is
there any chance of there being
a perception of trump doing better than
he actually is tonight
well i mean it's certainly true that you
know different
um the different parties have tendencies
of when their voters tend to
cast more votes but it's interesting to
look at a state like atlanta where you
have
you know most of the vote already
counted but the counties
that have not yet been counted are
more around the atlanta era which the
biden campaign is counting on
to go more strongly for them and that's
also the
state where we're seeing two senate
races so
you know we have um a democratic
challenger
john ossoff who's trying to uh unseat
republican
david perdue saying don't make any
declarations yet we're still waiting on
all these atlanta area votes to come in
and it could end up
flipping the race late into the night or
even into tomorrow and the next day
you mentioned these key senate races in
georgia i'm curious
what are some other down the ballot
races that you've been watching this
evening that are
key turning points in this election yeah
well we
and others have already called the house
of representatives for the
democrats that was no real surprise they
had a pretty strong majority going into
this and they were expected to
uh even pick up some seats this in this
election
we're definitely watching a bunch of
senate races
there are 14 races that were considered
competitive and
republicans were defending 12 of them so
one
uh seat that the republicans did pick up
was in alabama
uh incumbent democrat doug jones lost
his alabama senate seat
to a republican so we're gonna see how
the rest of the
night shakes out for the democratic
challengers happening to unseat all the
republicans
you know we're really looking at states
like north carolina where
cal cunningham is a democratic
challenger coming down to the wire
on whether or not he can unseat
republican incumbent
tom tillis and looking at the numbers
right now
uh why should folks who are hoping for a
biden win
uh be either concerned or hopeful about
these numbers
um what are what are the next kind of
big state announcements that people
should have their eyes peeled for
well definitely concerned because it's
not a
biden landslide i mean this is not a
comfortable night for the biden campaign
by any stretch of the imagination it is
going to come down to the wire
and you know we're looking at states
like arizona pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin
you know any configuration of those
states coming together
could mean an electoral college victory
for trump
or for biden and you know that's really
kind of the maddening thing about
the american system is that you you have
uh states that have different rules and
those states are worth different numbers
of electoral college votes
and it just takes a while for that
puzzle to come together and to get a
clear
picture of where we are at this point in
the night
and have you heard anything from folks
within the biden or trump campaigns
about
what needs to happen for either of them
to declare victory tonight
well biden himself said earlier today
that he's willing to wait until tomorrow
if there's nothing to be said he said
he's not going to
come out and just make some kind of
statement tonight just
for the sake of making a statement or
risk getting ahead of himself for the
results
um trump on the other hand is going to
take any opportunity that it looks like
he's ahead enough to declare himself the
way